[Music]
[Applause]
boom what's up everyone welcome to
simulation I'm your host Don sock young
very excited to be talking about wisdom
to be talking about thriving through
life through communities through sharing
each other's experiences and helping one
another across the world we have beau
ASCO and joining us on the show hey guys
nice to be here thanks for inviting me I
love your work so much thank you so much
likewise I'm super excited to talk about
all things whizzed oh that's good yeah
this is gonna be a lot of fun for those
that don't know Boaz is the CEO of
wisdom it's in the links in the bio
below wisdom and it's a platform that
connects people who've been through
similar experiences so they can learn
from people who have been there and he's
had 15 years in storytelling content
production Israeli mm-hmm Israeli born
and raised yes yes and has had previous
work as well with his company's medic
hope did London School of Economics and
global media and communications so we
like to we like to start our episodes
talking about big history all right
let's do it
okay so we have a find ourselves as as
stewards of Earth after a long period of
evolution and we're going through the
exponential technology age we're trying
to figure out how to work together seven
point eight billion of these human
primates so what is your current
synthesis on the state of humanity um
well I think you know it's doing well on
a whole I think it's you know destroying
the earth slowly but I think that when
you look at the types of knowledge that
people try to acquire one thing that we
we've seen clearly on the platform is
that even though we've become smarter
and we you know have gotten really great
at acquiring knowledge
how wisdom experience-based you know
knowledge that type of knowledge that
all of us reach out to in times of you
know meaning in need and the type of
with you know knowledge that was
humanity always relied on to make the
biggest decisions for some reason that
type of knowledge has eroded and the
role of that type of knowledge has been
diminished if you go back you know two
thousand four hundred years ago and you
know read Aristotle who you know
invented democracy and invented you know
narratives and storytelling and he also
you know looked at the types of
knowledge that one needs to live well
you mentioned thriving and he actually
did something really interesting so he
looked at the various types of knowledge
that are out there
scientific knowledge artistic knowledge
you know military knowledge and then he
ends up saying the type of knowledge
that you need to acquire to live well is
practical wisdom the reason is that that
is the only type of knowledge that you
can't have too much of so you can be see
too scientific and sort of disconnect
yourself from you know daily lives and
the lives of people who you know around
you you can be too artistic and then
that can translate into you know being
again too lofty or something you can be
too arrogant and too courageous and you
know and and and end up putting people
in harm in harm's way
but you can never be too wise so you
know when we take a step back and look
at the chronology and look at what's
missing in people's live we think that
what is missing to great extent is
wisdom and I encourage the people on you
know this show to think about you know
the type of the lessons that life has
taught them and how valuable they are or
can be to someone who's going through
something similar now and and that is
what we spend our time thinking about
okay that was a long answer that was
such a good answer
all right there's there's there's a
couple really
ways I think to take this first is this
understanding that over this period of
big history there has been a lot of
wisdom that has been passed along
through collaboration and communication
of the human species to one another
that's the reason why we are so smart is
because we're able to make language and
then save that and push it through these
generations building on top of it much
faster than just Adi it just DNA but we
have this this intelligence that we're
able to top on top of it
so then there is a lack of that today
where we look around and we see
ourselves lacking some of this hard
centric thinking lacking some of this
empathy and this love and this eye
contact and this how do we flourish
together across the planet not just
individual but with this Nash
equilibrium with this collective that's
at the same time so I like how you how
you put that into perspective with it is
so much about retaining these principles
of the best wisdoms over the years and
you bring the stay Aristotle tell us
about how you see that this process of
of retaining these important collective
wisdoms over time yeah tell us about
that so you know I think that when you
look at the evolution of how you know
humans have acquired knowledge I think
that for thousands of years the
assumption was that we all have access
to wisdom you know there's that elder
you know the village elder that we can
go and speak to there are people who we
can very readily and easily access and
that would teach us you know how to live
what we're missing is you know knowledge
we're missing you know that the eight
the Golden Age of the libraries you know
from Alexandria and onward I think the
knowledge graph you know that Google
amazingly built to some extent is a you
know founded on this thesis that if only
we could have you know an answer to any
question that
we can ask then then you know our
problems the humans will be solved I
think that what Facebook did with the
social graph is sort of you know work
with the hypothesis that if only we
would be connected to every person on
earth then you know our lives as humans
would be perfected I think what we're
seeing now is that a we are connected to
3.5 billion people or we will be by 2021
which is the number of people who are
going to be connected by social and we
have access to a tool that can answer
any question as long as someone asks it
before and still we feel alone and we
feel you know non wiser and I think what
happened is that that type of knowledge
called wisdom has been neglected
now that the social graph and the
knowledge graph to some extent to large
extent has been solved for I think we
need to think about the wisdom graph I
mean how do we capture wisdom organize
it and send it to the right person at
the right time without bad person group
without that person even knowing that
they should you know acquire that piece
of wisdom because wisdom you know the
thing about wisdom is that it's all the
things that you don't know that you
don't know so you can't even ask that
question on social on search because you
don't know what you ask so you know what
is what how can we you know proactively
acquire lessons that other people have
learned that we should acquire so we can
have a better tomorrow better next week
better next month better next year is
something that I think that technology
hasn't solved you know in our humble way
we are trying to solve that that that
challenge oh my gosh okay I'm so in love
with all you said okay so there's a
couple different things that you said
that's are super important there's a a
no knowledge graph of social graph in a
wisdom graph and and so what's very
interesting that we've been thinking
about a lot is this ultimate synthesis
of Civilizations knowledge
yep so let's say that you know a couple
thousand years ago the knowledge graph
wasn't as it was a more contracted it
wasn't as why and the reason because of
that is because of all these new
scientific revolution advancements that
have been pushing the edge of knowledge
out across different fields and then
there's the social graph like you said
now 3.5 billion humans soon will be
connected across all these different
social platforms and so then the
connectivity is increasing which is very
awesome and then how are we still
feeling somewhat alone and stuff like
that that's very strange it's weird why
are we more echo-chamber doubt and
cognitive ease doubt but that is so
strange but you know we can address it
if you like we yeah it's more that we
didn't we didn't have the right pieces
of our own evolution advanced enough
with to know that we are in an echo
chamber so we have to do better at
nuance of stuff and then this last part
is this wisdom graph and you pet you
painted this out so beautifully you said
that within this wisdom graph that's
been accumulating of human wisdom which
is somewhat similar to knowledge and
some in some ways there's maybe some
overlap of a Venn diagram style but this
wisdom that's been carried on over time
in this knowledge graph how do you
deliver it to the right human exactly at
the right time is such a beautiful
question and project to be working on
yes though so you mentioned that where
is that I'm Israeli and you know the
people that we in wisdom or based in
Israel there's another interesting
company called ways that came out of
Israel that everyone here uses yeah you
know fairly well and you know we sat
down with them as we began thinking
about this challenge and they talked
about how well basically what ways does
is you know they crowdsource maps and
they use existing data that is delivered
by people in real time to proactively
tell you you know how you should drive
your own kind of journey and where you
should take a ride away sure to collect
weathers or whatever you know something
on the road that you should be aware of
and how cool would it be if we could
due to life what ways did to traffic so
that was sort of the first metaphor that
that we you know went out to the world
with and then we you know we're eight
iris tall very deeply and it turns out
that if you can crowdsource life or the
structure of meaningful experiences if
you can get people to suggest what they
believe are the major junctions or major
steps what we call along any specific
journey and I'll give some examples so I
don't if you have kids but I do I have
two kids two kids in the exponential
technology world good luck how old are
they're big they're old they're older
they're all but the average the late
teen yeah one is my older son is 15 and
my younger daughter is 12 okay they're
in the smartphone age right now yeah
they are but they're good kids
they're good okay you know they're
brilliant and in all that do you know of
course but you know juice dad but you
know when you're when you're going
through something like parenting when
you're going through something like
divorce or building a home or depression
anxiety caregiving any one of these
major life events that one day present
themselves and say we're here and you're
gonna have to deal with us right and by
the way there's a standard stress scale
that talks about forty to just stress
creating consequential life experiences
that all of us will go through in life
so when that happens knowledge doesn't
play a big role in the decision you're
making the fact that you can connect to
build a building people doesn't matter
at all because what you're looking for
is that specific person who's been
through this specific moment that has
become part of your life so what if we
could crowdsource all that and invite
people to come up with the major steps
that any parent should know about so
breaking the baby back from hospital you
know that moment when you bring the
baby back home and you go well no one
talked about this moment now what the
hell am I supposed to do now
or you know let's take something as
challenging as breast cancer so sure
you're gonna go you know god forbid
you've been diagnosed you're gonna go to
Google you're gonna search for you know
how do I cope with my diagnosis you're
gonna get a million results of billing
results on you know chemotherapy and
clinical pathways etc but what about
steps like cutting your hair before
chemotherapy you know that moment that
every breast cancer patient or survivor
has gone through repeatedly described as
one of the most difficult moments along
that journey
what about telling your friends and
family they've been diagnosed what about
if you come out as gay what about that
moment when you come out to colleagues
you know it's like those moments that
require wisdom so what if we could
krauser is that what what if we could
build a map representing all of the
junctions of all of life's meaningful
experiences and what if we could
leverage that map to say well where are
you now
right what are you going through life
and you would go well you know I'm going
through anxiety I'm starting a business
you know I'm taking care of an older
parent and then I would go alright so
here are all the steps of people have
suggested suggested when you would go
been there been there been there have
been there or there now there now there
now and I would then take all that data
and say well you know Alan here's
someone that you should really speak to
you should speak to this person because
he and you share 436 steps and then you
should speak to that person because he's
been through with experiences that you
are very likely to experience even
though you don't know that which is what
the wisdom graph is about that is what
we're busy building
holy cow oh my gosh yeah I just my voice
so yeah I feel so good to have met you
you know likewise thank you so much
you're you're doing some of what I think
is yeah the most important work that
civilization needs to do building out
this wisdom graph and okay let's explain
this in a couple of points you say there
are these these junctures that we step
out on and even let's let's say the
child is born the child is born and then
the first thing is that this this period
of the first two to four months is so
crucial for the maternal infant
relationship to be really strong to not
have trauma that lasts long throughout
life to have that love and compassion
all these basic needs met and whatnot
then we have these these junctions like
you said of immediately when they're
coming back from from from the hospital
then there's when we're going through
any of these life circumstances really
losing losing someone in our life like a
grandparent or a parent
yep having some sort of a health issue
doing something that maybe like
depressive or anxious or or or any you
have so many of these listed actually we
can we can we can show you right here
how many of them actually exists there's
tons you know on the site you guys offer
this these experience from from member
members to enter the anxiety group the
motherhood group relationship advice
depression LGBTQ chronic pain this list
is is it's extremely long because there
are so many different junctions for
people to arrive at right and then
there's a bunch of data around machine
learning and artificial intelligence to
be able to see that if I've been to 400
of these similar steps that you have
that you are good even though you might
be in Israel and I may be in California
it's still better for us to connect
digitally than it is for me to connect
to someone locally that may only have a
hundred of the same steps that me and so
then there's there's that connection
that occurs and then there's another
connection which is let's say there are
two people that each have about two
hundred steps one in Israel one in
California that I walk
then I might want to connect to the one
in San Francisco because then I can go
meet them in person and have
face-to-face eye-to-eye conversation yep
you know similarity is one type of match
I think as I said you know they're
diverse differences that produce
matchings that are even wiser than
similarity I think one thing that we've
seen very clearly on the platform I mean
you know that the experience that you
mentioned are all experiences people
have suggests suggested and crowdsource
which is why the list is so long and it
reflects the you know that the audience
or the demographic that that we you know
that we're seeing involved with the
platform which is the 18 to 34
demographic currently but I think that
as we scale we'll see it you know with
things like retirement and you know
interesting yeah debt you know
remarrying
right now we have reddit threads as kind
of the place for many people for how to
handle some tough things like debt there
are some people that are talking about
how to get out of debt how to work out
better how to do these things reddit
threads are kind of well I'll read it
you know it's a platform that we've
studied very deeply and and you know
there's some brilliant people working
there I think you know the thing about
wisdom is that there are two components
that you know make wisdom what it is
which I think current online platforms
lack one is structure so you know if
this is unstructured content if this is
you know subreddit which is there's a
flat hierarchy between you know
subreddits
you know that is not necessarily wisdom
wisdom is something that you would
acquire and would be sensitive to your
location in a certain trajectory so that
that is one thing the other is empathy
you know think about a good friend that
you would describe as wise you would sit
down with that person and he will tell
you something it would it would turn
into wisdom if you would really think
that he is giving you a piece of advice
with good intentions
with a desire that you would come out of
this well and you would go well this is
a really wise person right so you know
we have you know a hierarchy of users
which is another part of the wisdom
graph that are basically prioritized by
how helpful they are to other people
yeah so that's when you can score more
points and have more say in in helping
people exactly and versus maybe it's
harder to tell when someone can be
helpful
that's anonymous versus someone that has
already built up quite a bit of points
in helping people with their with where
they're at at their junctions in life
especially when they walked into similar
junctions with similar steps so you know
that the there's a lot of you know AI
and work going into that what makes a
helpful person you know what
differentiates someone you know from
someone who is less helpful in an online
platform so you know we count helpful
scores you know there's a reaction
called helpful we don't have a leg
button we do have a helpful reaction
which is a whole different ball game we
have a reaction called bin there and
imagine how powerful it is that you're
writing something very personal and
someone clicks been there and you know
that you and him or her share the same
you know life path or a moment whoa so
is that this when you cook bin there
does that add the steps that you guys
have been on the same step we know that
you to have an affinity and we would use
that to match you with people who've
been through similar steps you'd also be
sending a push to that person and that
person would know that someone in this
world has been through that specific
thing that they wrote about and almost a
third of the people who get that
reaction go back to the platform and
start a one-on-one conversation with
that person who give them who gave them
to been there you know click which I
think is a reflection of how you know
deeply all of us yearn for a meaningful
non-judgemental personal connection with
someone who's been there I mean what's
more human than that so you know to go
back to the question about you know
early childhood and what happens there I
think that you know there's a quote
there's an interesting question about
identity you know who are we as people
are we you know are we the number of
friends that we have you know that's one
question one type of answer I think the
social graph did did that to manatee you
know we are if we have 10,000 followers
or we if we have 10,000 friends then you
know somehow we are worth more than
someone who has 500 friends that's one
way to look at it I think another way to
look at it is to say you are what you've
been through in life so which is very
astute alien I mean I read Aristotle
talked about and this is my from my life
as a you know storyteller and writer he
talked about characters so what's a
character a character is the stuff that
that character does right it's not what
that character says about themselves you
know it's not what other people say
about them
a thief is someone that steals right and
a clown or someone's funny is someone
that makes other people laugh so we are
our actions in the same sense we are the
things that we'd go through in life what
we're trying to do and what wisdom is
about is trying to connect people
through what they've been through in
life and also recognizing that if you've
been through caregiving and anxiety and
depression and a parenting then you know
these are like badges that you've earned
like these are stripes that you should
wear proudly because each and every one
of these experiences you know filled you
with a treasure trove of knowledge that
can you know deeply help someone and if
we would only be able to if we you know
people would be more inclined or we
realize how gratifying it is to give
that knowledge
that experience based knowledge to
someone that would change their lives
and if we're you know we consistently
are looking at what makes people feel
better and and we and we treat this as a
data project right there's not you know
sort of a this amorphic kind of
exploration we you know we surveyed our
users as they went into is though we
served they we surveyed them again two
weeks after that we sound loneliness you
know reduce by 17 points and when we you
know double click on that and trying to
understand why it is because a we
connected them with people who've been
there but B we help them help you know
we connected them to someone whose life
can change even in a small you know
small scale way we find meaning in life
from also delivering help exact other
people exactly so then that also can be
worse people potentially may feel like
they can gain a lot of of they can spend
their time on Wisco delivering help to
other people that need it and this isn't
they do and they do amazing to see and
it's also interesting that this
democratizes in a sense that whenever we
hear people visiting psychiatrists or
was any therapist or having these these
events where you do things like circling
where you go and you just become really
vulnerable and really open to just
listening to how other people feel and
showing them that you understand them
that that is really cool because it's
yeah it's democratizing the this entire
process as long as again that this is
benevolent in many that you that this is
difficult because now you must be the
ones that kind of do a little bit of
making sure that someone else isn't
coming on to cause level it's that can
be tough to you know we there's a way to
do this I think the first step is to set
expectations so this platform is a
peer-to-peer community
where people help each other so if you
are here because you want to do other
stuff then you know then at some point
if you break the code of conducts then
you would be warned and you know and if
you repeat that behavior which is
unhelpful then you would be asked to
leave so you know the way this is
enforced their watchlist which we you
know studied with the Wikipedia folks
and you know they have this in place for
a while the watchlist include you know
highlighted words that are words of you
know concern users are watch listed if
they're repeated offenders and then we
have a hierarchy of moderators you know
ways did that well I think you know the
reason that today when you drive you
don't drive you or you know your car
into the sea even if someone you know
decided to somehow cheat the system and
you know troll it by you know sort of
driving for two weeks you know back and
forth just so that data point would be
added to the map is because they're
moderators who earned their way to be
editors on the platform and that that is
why the platform is so safe so we did
the same there's a hierarchy of
moderators we still got in Wikipedia as
well yeah absolutely
and there aren't any editing rights on
the platform and and they keep it safe
so and you know I'll say another thing
it's really interesting to see people
when they are in a positive environment
tend to behave more positively than when
they're you know in a destructive
environment it's the famous broken
window oh very like the YouTube comments
section is already a place of great at
times malevolence and at times there is
some wisdom that is and but but then on
platforms like wisdom when it is meant
specifically for helping peer-to-peer
helping each other
and it is easier for people to
understand that when they get on the
platform and that's what they're there
for
and there's a collective you know
understanding that this platform is
addressing a specific need which is you
know organizing and delivering
experience based knowledge and if
someone is there for a different reason
then the community itself is gonna say
hey you know what's up this is not what
this is for this is not for data if you
want to date there are other platforms
other products out there so you know I
think it can be done I think we're
seeing it happening it's very exciting
and I think we're again we're tapping
into a very fundamental human behavior
that has been neglected by tech it's
such a crucial point the the the so
interesting that technology as a tool is
being used in ways that we are now
understanding our wisdom and stepping up
and saying hey we should be using
technology more so as a tool that is
specifically benevolent as in many ways
as possible and helpful in as many ways
as possible and so we're kind of slowly
eradicating and ethically growing or
addict ating some of the malevolence is
and and and growing ethically and it
it's doing things like like what we see
with with whizzed oh this seems you have
these options you have this option for
people to click on I've been there you
have this option for people to click on
this was helpful and when you have these
new sorts of of ways instead of just
liking and tweet retweeting and whatnot
that we've now we're now evolving it's a
helpful and been there's right what
other sorts of reactions can we have
where technology can evolve and these
ethics and morals can evolve to where we
can communicate better we can help with
this wisdom graph actually expanded
greater and connect these communities of
people that are
similar things to more more effectively
get through some of the experiences that
are most meaningful in our lives would
do it with community so I'll give you
two examples one is you know this
concept of a sponsor or what we call a
buddy program so one of the first things
that you encounter when you join whizz
though is you know you go through the on
board you say here are the things that
I'm going through in life you're
presented with all the you know that the
maps representing the structure of that
experience based on other people's
experiences you click through bin
they're there now you land in the
platform and then we say to you you have
two options one is you can dive in you
know there are millions of people
talking about what it is that we got
you're going through every profile that
you're going to look at the first thing
that you're going to see is the
experiences that both of you share so
you and this person whose profile you're
looking at share four experiences and
500 steps
I mean imagine how powerful it is to be
an environment where you're surrounded
by people that you can measure the
affinity with every single second yeah
the other option that we say to you is
or offer to you is we can match you with
a buddy if you'd like we can find that
one person who exists somewhere on earth
with whom you have an incredible
affinity that person is a helpful member
of the community they earned a helpful
helper badge we know that if you're
gonna write to that person he's gonna
respond quickly because he's there to
help and if you'd like you can you know
we can do that match and you can
immediately started one in one
conversation with that person 45% of our
you know registered user base does that
the response rate of helpers is 92%
which is something that it took us took
us a few months to optimize and perfect
so you know that is one example I think
that all of us in our offline lives have
experienced that moment where we were
looking for that one person you know
that would understand what it is that
we're going through with whom we would
be able to have a meaningful deep
helpful moving
and we do it digitally because I think
that we've matured to a place where we
understand that quantity of people
serves a certain need and quality of
people serves a whole different need
dang that's a really good point yeah
that's a really good point there's
there's that and then there's the one
you brought up even prior to that which
was this dynamic ability to measure
people's affinities with each other
that's really interesting I don't think
we've really explored that too much this
idea that when I'm walking around on the
streets that usually it takes me five or
ten minutes to get into a conversation
with someone where we can see that we've
had the similar junctions in life and
that we could be good resources to each
other but what if you could just see the
number you know on the wisdom of oh
they're for similar junctions as you and
then you get to more easily communicate
with them and learn and grow that's
that's think of this is a like you know
imagine a superpower you know imagine
walking down the street and as you look
towards every single person on the
street you would know this person has
gone through five experiences that I've
been through that person has been
through eleven you know experience is
that person in the bus stop you know
went through 25 experiences that I've
been through I mean how would you feel
you know you would feel you know not
alone much stronger much more empowered
and you would you know reach out to
those people and have meaningful
conversations both on stuff that you
want to ask them and also offer them you
know stuff that they are walking around
with I would approach people way more
often yeah there you go with if I could
just know that all day so many
affinities with this person but that has
you also have to be a little bit careful
with that too because sometimes we want
to
while we want to surround ourselves with
people that we have lots of affinities
with we also want to surround ourselves
with people that we may it's this is a
very careful distinguishment between
affinity in terms of being at similar
junctions in life in terms of going
through maybe a depressive time going
through a parent dying going through
being a mother or father etc okay okay
those junctions fine but these junctions
of propelling echo chambers of thinking
as in if they're already pro-abortion or
pro-gay or pro immigration or pro
nationalism or pro whatever that then
you must be very careful then but you
don't tie those affinities but that's
that's that exactly is the difference
because I think the social graph what it
does it creates those eco chambers
because the recommendations or the
matches are based on you know similar
network of friends who are interested in
the same type of things well on whist oh
the wisdom graph matches people who've
been through similar experiences so we
see this in the plaque on the platform
all the time you know these two people
that couldn't be more different
you know politically financially
whatever you know one is a conservative
the other is a Democrat one is rich the
other is you know less well-off and and
you know and they're having amazing
conversations and they couldn't be more
close because they lost a parent they
you know one of their spouses is going
through breast cancer they they want to
change their job etc etc etc and you
know and the glue that is holding them
together is human affinity as opposed to
network affinity which is a whole
different ballgame whoa okay so now I'm
following that the social graph is
affinities are propelled echo chambers
it's more about that you've both liked
Hillary Clinton or Donald Trump or
whatever that
is that's how that happens with wisdom
and wisdom knowledge graph a wisdom
graph is more about being at similar
junctions of life experience which can
then bring together people from
different knowledge areas different
beliefs of how civilization should be
structured but then they have a
similarity yeah that they can be met
that's very cool
okay so this is this is this has been
super interesting so far I want to show
people what what we're talking about in
terms of okay so there's a couple things
first is I want to show I want to show
that the kind of the steps on on how on
how it works
yep that you share your unique story you
meet people who've been there and then
you chat and help with others yep and
you make friends for life that's your
this is your several steps to this
process and then on the on the sections
we read some of the section some of the
communities that you can join but I want
to read these because we don't actually
realize how often we don't realize what
human experience how vast of human
experience actually is the spectrum of
all the different styles of life
experience that you can have and so when
I was reading this list with you I was
like oh my gosh so there's things like
I'm death I'm coming out I'm losing
weight I have depression I have anxiety
I need relationship advice I'd like to
talk about body positivity
I've bipolar disorder I've breast cancer
I want to get motivated I'm a mother I'm
a father
LGBTQ sexual assault ADHD chronic pain
autism caregiving I mean talk about a
spectrum and a variety of human
experiences and how many of those
junctions are people at in different
different ways how many people are
experiencing how a lot of
these things may be way less of one of
these things but then how do you measure
that how do you link up someone that's
only 20% in one of these categories with
another person that's only 20% one of
these categories so I was just my mind
was so blown when I was exposed to like
this is the variety of human experiences
and that took about to bind people in
these communities so let's ask you that
question then how do you know when
someone is maybe only experiencing like
20% wanting conversation about getting
motivated versus they want like 90% of
conversation about getting motivated so
you know just again from a data-driven
perspective and it really helps to think
about this from a you know data-driven
perspective otherwise you can get lost
and you know in the complexity of this
thing so here's one interesting data
point the average number of experiences
that with though user has on the
platform is five so what happens is they
go into through the platform with one
kind of urgent need or a need that is
more important to them than other
experiences on the platform from the
long list that you read but then as they
use the platform are introduced to other
people they end up adding at least four
and the average is five so this is an
interesting framework that the average
person is going through five major
experiences at any single moment I mean
think about yourself I'm sure you can
you know think about what those are and
they change through life you know so
let's talk about myself so you know I'm
running a business I'm taking care of an
older mom I am a father I am a husband
and you know and you know I'm writing
I'm writing a play whatever or
constructing a work of art right so
these are the five experiences that make
up my current human condition and they
and they're gonna change as I you know
get older evolved etc etc so that is one
data point and then the question is to
your question I think if that's the
framework the question is what was the
first experience that I that I came
through and then what in which order did
I add the additional experiences so the
way we're looking at this you know
wisdom is what is what are the strongest
correlations between experiences and
then within an experience what are the
correlations between the specific steps
so I'll give you some examples if you're
going through college and you've added
the college timeline to your profile
there's 50% chance that the second
timeline or you know experience map that
you would add to your profile is anxiety
and I think that's that's fascinating
and the reason is the reason why it's
fascinating is that you would never
think about that as a college student
right you know you would go to Google
you're gonna search college to death
you're gonna go on whatever Facebook
Facebook groups look for stuff you know
about college and how to survive it but
what you should really be doing from a
wisdom Graf's perspective is looking for
finding helpful people who have been
through anxiety and you know learning
from them how to you know take that on
in a more efficient way imagine if the
young people that were going and
entering through college that were
entering the second time - anxiety where
immediately paired with a mentor that
has been through the process where they
just described wisdom what we're doing
you know I'll give you another example
caregiving which is something that I
know very closely because I you know it
took care of my dad you know when he
when he was ill is very closely tied
with you know body image issues because
as you're taking care of someone who's
older you you know neglect yourself and
you become less healthy and we know that
from the data so this is examples from
you know correlations between first
experience and the second experience
that you add to your profile then we
also look at the relationship between
steps so I'll give you a you know a
trivial you know example if you're
coming out then you know chances are
that you're gonna spend a lot of time
thinking about coming out to friends and
family right that moment where you say
you know mom dad I'm gay how do you
phrase that how do you say that but
ninety seven percent of people who click
been there on that step also click you
know either there now or been there on a
step called coming out to colleagues
which is different you know it's a
different dynamic these are people who
are less close to you but you know
you've just made a very important
decision in your life chances are that
maybe you want to you know talk about
that and we know that if you've been
here then chances are that you're gonna
be there and you should speak to this
guy
who knows something about it that is
such a good example and they're diff and
they're different in their nuance you
will find that taking a step towards
talking to your parents about how you
feel about something is different than
talking to your colleagues about how you
feel then it's different than talking to
your best friends then your brother or
sister potentially etc there's that that
nuance is very interesting and that you
can map how people are following that to
that second point on the coming out I
would never search for that you know
that's the thing because you would not
know that that is something that
is gonna be something that you're gonna
be bothered by because no one reflects
to you their way forward there's zero
visibility it's like you're driving
blindly oh yeah down this road through
the junctions to normally were driving
through a foggy dust storm exactly and
then when you get when you get this
these are these steps with machine
learning that can show you they can
separate some of the fog and the dust
out of the way by giving you additional
connections it can be you know I guess
there there can be times there
potentially to be a little bit weary
that you don't nudge someone in a
direction that they may not be wanting
to even go that okay well we see that
you've been on depression do you also
feel somewhat anxious do you also feel
somewhat suicidal this is we don't do
that
yeah correct and this is also very good
that because this is when people walk
into that and that very anxious state
into the into the clinic and they're
going to speak to a psychiatrist and
they're and they're filling out their
states of anxiety and depression
suicidal thinking and stuff the
questions sometimes feel like they're
all leaning you towards the most you
know negative states so this can be very
harmful at times as well so you tell us
about the process and how you don't how
you don't do that so how would you judge
someone into like fall so we don't nudge
you know we don't nudge at all I mean
the only thing that we do is you know
highlight or you know present to you
people that you might want to start a
conversation with so okay when you look
at a certain say you're in a specific
group say you're going through
depression and you click on the members
list in the depression group that we
just you know recommended that you check
out the people in that group are going
to be ordered by how similar they are
and their experiences to you and to long
list of people but you'll see the number
of steps per person and then you can you
know look at their profile check out how
many helpful scores they have whether
the contribute
they've put on an whist oh how many love
reactions they you know they've received
did they get reviewed
I mean helpers and buddies on the
platform get reviews from people that
they helped it's on their profile so you
can check out how helpful someone was
and then you can make a decision an
informed decision about the people that
you want to start a conversation with so
that's the extent by which we you know
would present you with people that you
have in search for okay but we try to
create like a discovery mode where you
would be able to reach out to those guys
that have a meaningful conversation
where we are more proactive is when you
join us and we say you know if you'd
like we can match you up with a buddy
and based on what you've been through we
would recommend someone that we know is
helpful so the helpful or the helpers as
we call them are there about 15% of our
user base these are the best most
helpful most positive most empowering
users on the platform and if we
recommended that you get in touch with
them then chances are that even if
you're down you're gonna finish that
conversation feeling much better about
yourself the other way that we treat
this is you know we talked about watch
list so if someone uses I mean there's
their super guides on the platform that
control watch list there that are you
know ingrained in the platform so if
someone uses a word like suicide or
someone uses a word like knife or you
know thinking about the end or stuff
like that that would send an automatic
push to a super guide in a specific
group so they would be able to quickly
check out that post and see whether it's
a problematic post or not and if it is
then you know they're gonna reach out to
that person and say hey what's going on
can we help and and the response rate or
the you know the time that it takes to
find that person and
have a conversation about the specifics
post is is you know like it's very very
brief and we're getting better at better
at doing that there's like you just
described there is this interesting sort
of a bell curve and you have on one end
of the bell curve you have these sort of
extremely positive helpers that are that
are helping a lot of people they have a
disproportionate amount of the amount of
people that have said that they've been
helpful and whatnot and then there's
people on the other side of the bell
group that have been that you need to
put on watch lists and sometimes banned
from the platform because they're maybe
they're just being malevolent and then
there's the majority of people in the
center of the bell curve they're just
trying to talk to a couple people and
get advice and stuff that's that's
that's interesting that you're
experiencing those in that you have to
moderate in the sense and then I wanna I
wanna I want to show this I think this
is important for people that haven't
seen yet so here we're under the you
know relationship advice this is kind of
would it be like you have this option
here of you know you know Jackie said
Jackie how did he how did he get you to
come back and then you have an option to
heart insightful been there you know so
I am back living with my ex after he
wanted to be alone as in single but he
acts as if we never broke up so there's
this interesting conversation here
happening my Lisa ended I had a crash
somewhere so humans are going through
these experiences and the fact there's
already someone that has that has been
there that you're now talking to about
this and that has this like this is a
use there's a high utility here for the
people that's missing something similar
there was another see this is also
interesting to me so there's this one as
well which is Sarah so this is Sarah
snow has been through 14 steps you
follow in motherhood so this is pairing
together a mom with another mom that has
been through 14 of these similar steps
and it goes something like hi I'm Beth
and I just found out that I'm six
pregnant congratz breath I have two and
half year old daughter and two months
old son what would you like to know
about the road ahead so this again is
just another really interesting example
of how you can connect like you said
what are you gonna do when you're
pregnant what do you do when you come
home with your kid how are you going to
maximize your efficiency with being good
parent well a good way to do it is to
have a community of people that have
been in through these similar steps and
and here's you know one last one last
thing that I want to show you know these
have been these are some videos of how
you know parenting a child with OCD how
I explained cancer to my son
why raising a child with autism is an
incredible gift my coming-out story
mm-hmm so this is this is wizard oh this
is wisdom yeah this is your platform how
many people are working on building this
now a total a grand total of 13 they're
doing amazing people and this is across
tel-aviv and Mill Valley
it's across Tel Aviv Syracuse New York
and Los Angeles and Los Angeles and
Syracuse okay and 13 and it's mostly
then designers software engineers and a
little bit of like machine learning data
science so those are the kind of the
three main that feels cool and do we
know approximately how many people are
using are we able to share sure yeah
yeah we have around half a million
registered users listen we think that
this is one of those platforms that all
of us need and there's no reason at all
if you know if we continue to grow as we
think we should be growing that in 10
years you know people would be you know
it's gonna be difficult for them to
imagine their lives with
wisdom just just as people can't imagine
their lives without Google or ways or
any one of these platforms because I
mean think about it it's like it's crazy
you know we go through life you know our
mouse you we use our phone to drive we
use our phone to choose a restaurant we
use our phone as search and when we're
but as we go through you know life's
most meaningful experiences we go
through them blindly and alone and the
role of Technology in that space which
is you know the most important moments
in our lives is non-existant and that
needs to change which is why we built
this thing yeah that's that's why I
foresee this going from you know five
hundred million five hundred thousand
users to five hundred million users in
the next ten years be I hope so I hope
that this becomes as frequently used a
search in maps like you're saying
because this is that the journey of
life's most meaningful experiences and
to have wisdom from other people that we
can commune on is so crucial along that
journey Wow and it can also fix you know
it can also fix some of the biggest
elements of you know social that all of
us have been talking about reading about
etc etc I mean it can solve for
loneliness the sense of being
disconnected it can solve for the whole
you know non authentic fake you know
contributions of debate because on West
oh you're you're reading stuff that was
written by people who've been through
those things and it can get more
authentic than that I think you know
social has been great at connecting us
to you know multitude of people but I
think the dynamic there is to expose you
to sort of the glamorize life that other
people are not living but they're you
know they're posting those posts because
that's the dynamic
I think that if we can raise the level
of authentic wheel contributions and
connect people based on similar life
experiences I think the online universes
can evolve into something much healthier
as we talk about these beats yeah look
at that I'm speechless
yeah it's right as we talk about some of
the malevolence and the ethical
quandaries that we face in the attention
economy and in and in some of the
business plans that the way that they're
structured and addictive technologies
that are in place that this is a good
way to this is this is one of those
positives that we can use technology in
these ways just like we used it in maps
and search we can use it in in gathering
a wisdom graph and connecting with
people based on being at similar
junctions in life and having similar
steps that we've taken yeah there's so
many of these examples like you listed
earlier when you're a college student
and you enter and then you also enter
the anxiety timeline well immediately
you're paired with a mentor that can
help you that if you yeah you whatever
it is like this that you can get paired
immediately with someone that can help
you based on data based on life
experiences this is this is really
important it's a really crucial stuff
and I think this is where technology is
headed this is kind of like the tech the
social media 2.0 scene is stuff like
this where it is social media for good
rather than social media specifically
for extracting at like attention and
advertising dollars so okay let's let's
ask before we ask a couple quick
questions on a show I just want to ask
you did we do you think we covered a
decent amount of the structure is there
another important thing that you think
is to cover to mention no I think you
know I think we cover the important
components of the platform I you know I
think that the more people join us the
better
the service that we can provide I mean
we have seen that in the data just to
give you by the way a few data points
you know when we suppose sat down the
waste guys they talked about the you
know natural distribution between
contributors and consumers online so
usually it's the you know it's the
ninety-nine $1.99 one rule where ninety
percent or a passive consumers nine
percent are contributors of content and
one percent are you know highly engage
users moderators etc that's what you
would find on ways you know QP D etc etc
on West Oh forty five percent of the
user base are contributors so everyone
is talking to someone because the
connections are so they're not
friendships or bonds you know they're
they're long lasting human connections
where people are prone to having
conversations with others the other
thing that we've seen is that again the
more we have people on the platform the
better matches we can provide because
just the you know the network is bigger
and richer totally and we can get better
at better at finding that special person
who can really change your life so you
know I'm sure all of the people come on
the show you know say you know invite
your viewers to choose yeah download the
app but I'm saying this in the context
of not not just from an acquisition
point of view but we want to provide the
best value tool and we want to provide
the best matches and the more people we
have on the platform the better we can
get at helping people and through some
of the most consequential moments over
their lives yes so if you want to help
other people you know join us and find
that one person who's waiting out there
for you to you know to change your lives
for the better
yeah absolutely that's a that's a great
that's a great call to action point is
is getting getting involved with with
wisdom is is it's free across iOS and
Android right and is there a way that
you guys are able to to sustain and grow
with the model
that your monetization so the model that
we're going with which we're playing
around with is a marketplace we're
trying to stay away from mass
advertising which I don't think is a
model that has proved you know
trustworthy from a user standpoint
necessarily I think what we've found
that people do perceived as helpful is
if we can highlight service providers
who have services to offer to people who
are going through specific you know life
events awesome and if those services
have been highly rated by other people
you've been through that's where those
specific experiences and people actually
see this as a service because when you
go through you know caregiving parenting
any one of these experiences that I've
been through you spend a ton of money
right you're trying to buy your way out
of ambiguity and and often you make a
ton of mistakes and very costly mistakes
so if we can help you find out you know
who is that where is that person that
you don't know that you don't know that
you should know we also can become a
place where we would say hey you know
here's someone who has a whatever
five-step program to overcome anxiety or
make you feel better about yourself or
better about your body better about your
you know mental state and you know 1500
people who've been through the steps
that you've been through gave that
person you know four-star review and the
average is 4.8 when we show that then we
suck we see very high conversion to
people who purchase either a one-on-one
with that person or a monthly
subscription to speak to that person or
a group you know moderated with that
person so that's that's the model that
we're exploring and you know and we
think it can help us scale yeah I really
enjoy that you are going against the
tide with advertising I agree even you
know we here are so focused on being
able to sustain through other methods
that are not pay walling that stuff is
it doesn't work when your ethics are
tied
the heart centric progress of humanity
you wouldn't pay while someone getting
wisdom from other people you just like
we wouldn't pay while people getting
content that is really important and I
like how you talk about this marketplace
modeling it immediately started running
some creative juices in my mind like
yeah if you want to get motivated and
you're talking to someone else that's
been through a juncture getting
motivated you guys can place a local gym
or a local maybe Tony Robbins event or
whatever into their feed and they can go
and explore that event and you guys can
potentially get a commission and that
can support you guys growing for your
engineering and operations and actually
making this platform what it is so
that's a I like that marketplace idea
that's very good ok so the couple quick
questions on the way out what would you
say is a core driving principle of your
life helping people I think it's the I
think it's the one tested and proven
model to feel better about yourself
that's a short answer but I really do
believe that I think that you know when
you're going through a moment of
difficulty or joy but it's new and you
know you're all centered you're focused
on yourself then that puts you in a
certain mental state but if you're able
to you know go out of yourself and
concentrate on transferring knowledge to
someone else based on what you've been
through and see that Prince's life
change then you would feel immensely
better about yourself and people who do
that repeatedly and I know quite a few
of them you know many of them are with
their users they're not all them people
who you know invest their lives in
helping other people they're just
happier so that's that's my motto
I love that and totally agree yeah we
gained a lot of our most deepest meaning
in life from from helping from helping
others okay how about this wouldn't be
simulation if we didn't ask you are we
in a simulation um wow that's a big one
I don't think it matters you know
doesn't matter I think you know this is
the this is the reality that we were
dealt
we're surrounding but we're surrounded
by other people and a certain reality
and I think our role in this reality
inexistent is to you know to make them
make the best of it there's one go you
know and it's not you know it's finite
so make the most of it and enjoy it and
do the things that you love and be the
person that you want to be and it
doesn't you know it doesn't really
matter if turns out to be a video game
what matters is as long as we're in it
we you know we we make the most of it
it's such a short time it's a blink of
an eye and to level up our characters
the most in the story is very important
and yet yeah
a lot of that comes from providing value
to to the collective as well alright and
the last question what is the most
beautiful thing in the world
I think it's a well-crafted story I
think that stories have an optimal
architecture and I think that there are
stories out there that have been crafted
in an optimal way and when you consume
them as a viewer as a listener etc etc
you end up feeling that you consume
something that was just perfect and that
feeling is is you know what art is for
but those pieces of art those stories
that take us from one place through a
journey and end up with us looking back
which is what the Greek wanted us to do
and say wow it really learned something
by consuming this perfect story without
me having to go through this you know
ordeal that the hero just went through
for an hour and a half we feel cleansed
and purified and to me perfect stories
are are the most beautiful things makes
me want to finish up on this ultimate
synthesis of civilizations story and
make that into a very fun and relatable
way of increasing people's awareness to
how we got here and you're doing that
doing that well it's on the way for sure
it's on the way boys it's on the way
this has been such a pleasure likewise
thank you so much for inviting me and we
love you so much
likewise you're doing such important
work well you know you're you're the one
collecting all this wisdom you know
daily so kudos to you thank you and it's
it's thanks to thanks T it's thanks to
you guys that you guys continue to check
out this content we really appreciate
you guys watching the show hugely
appreciate it we'll continue being at
that edge of knowledge for you for sure
so important to be at the edge and
whizzed only at the edge again the links
in the bio below here you can see again
wisdom we're from people who've been
there going sign up on the App Store or
on Google Play go and get that everyone
go and check it out
go and join these communities and have
this positive social use technology for
these positive social wisdom graph
interactions I love it I love it I love
it and go and build the future everyone
go and manifest your destiny into the
world we love you so much and we will
see you soon peace thank eyes thank you
thanks for watching